you walk into a room and you glow I
would move you up here I would too yeah
oh yeah get over here
we weren't supposed to cry today
[Music]
obviously model like long songs
yeah like just overall like beautiful
like definitely like get a very nice
body like hearing that from all of you
means so so much to me like thank you I
completely disagree
and I and I just like really really
appreciate that you have like my ideal
body type for myself preference so I'm
gonna switch with you
I don't know like I
I agree work out you're fit like you
look amazing
get over here yeah I don't want to hear
it yeah I definitely want to move my
move my to the end why why because I
feel like I'm very short you know but
that doesn't happen but your body is
beautiful I don't know I feel like all
of you guys are way more beautiful than
me you are petite but I mean that's
still you could be you could have a good
body type I think that accommodates
petite in a good one accommodates length
so I think that your body suits you
being someone who has had work done it's
really tough because like on one hand
you want to like please yourself and you
want to be comfortable in your body like
I guess I was I was comfortable I've
always been confident in my body but
like at the same time like you grew up
with all these things like being like
shoved down your throat and you do want
to conform to a certain extent exactly I
did get surgery I've gotten my body done
I've gotten my nose done I've gotten my
lips done from a long time ago I feel
like there's just like this standard of
like Beauty we all like strive to look
that way I have a child and like my it
shows in my body so like I go back and
forth a lot with myself it's like I want
to get work done or I'm like am I
getting it done because I wanted done or
am I getting it done because
like Society like am I okay with the
scars that I have from childbirth I'm
still learning to love myself like as I
am but my biggest overall like
insecurity is my body like I have blue
skin I have stretch marks like and like
a lot of people like who have kids like
that don't happen to them until like
multiple children I have one child
there's this whole movement going on
right now with representation but it's
still I have such an unhealthy
relationship with my body because I'm
not supposed to like the thing that
holds me back from living the lives that
you guys get to live and I want to live
you know when I wanted to put you near
the top it wasn't like for the purpose
of representation I genuinely like your
body is amazing
to like I don't know right exactly it's
just like you're genuinely like again
like no surprise that you were a model
you kind of have like the natural body
you know and that's not to say that like
plastic surgery you know is bad or
whatever but that would be like kind of
how I would kind of adjust that and then
I would switch with you because you have
like the more model-esque like athletic
kind of body type oh you want to switch
yes oh I thought I was going behind you
I feel like you should stay where you're
at
her where
so yeah over
here's the thing's always like picture
yourself on a dating app if you were
someone swiping through an app and you
were looking at people based off of a
picture and you saw someone who was a
wheelchair user would you swipe yeah
hell yeah
being in a wheelchair like you a bad
she's speaking to society as a
whole yeah I'm not often seen as sexy in
mainstream media as a disabled woman
there's not really a place yet for
people like me to feel sexy I think like
if we want to acknowledge the trends I'd
switch you too if we're going based on
society I feel like this ranking would
probably be pretty more accurate yeah
okay
probably switch with you just because I
think like this is like who these
clothes are meant to be on if that makes
sense everybody's gonna wear them it's
gonna be her I should bring you
in front of her just my preference
because you said some of this is
thrifted and this is also something that
I can see myself wearing but this is my
personal preference
I actually wanted to put Barbie here in
the front I really yeah like you have
the whole like the whole head to toe
going on seriously there's like not one
stone untouched we're looking at like
hair and makeup everything your hair is
like just you know and then my hair is
just like and then your hair you know
just on that point I would probably move
here just because I didn't do anything
with my hair
um I love it I like them now I think
your style works for you like like
you're like very much like
I can tell like you like plants and like
you like to go get crystals and very
mystical and like but you're like
natural you're like naturally beautiful
like that girl that just like wakes up
and goes yeah so like and your style
shows that I would personally bring you
in front of her your style is cute but
it's not something that I envisioned
myself wearing I would probably move you
back to the front I would bring you
before her as well yeah because I'm so
insecure about my body I wear big baggy
stuff I don't feel like I have a body
type that I feel like I really hope that
after this like you really like start
wearing like more like revealing yeah
y'all got me thinking I'm off for the
hose okay but like reveal a little bit
more your body's beautiful and like you
can see from a bunch of women that we
all agree yeah take that off like I love
that I love that even more now that you
took it off yeah yeah okay where do you
feel like yourself comes from my mom
I've always has grown up thrifting with
my mom so whatever I liked and it
doesn't matter what anybody else likes
it's what I like and I've had people
tell me like oh I don't really like that
but like you really pull that off right
right it's because it's all about the
confidence you have inside to pull off
with whatever you want to wear yeah it's
all about inside yeah I think we're good
where we're at I think everybody agrees
like where we're at right yeah
I'm gonna take you
yeah I will put you up here
um I'm gonna put myself down here I'm
horrible at makeup I'm going with you I
would put you right up at the front yeah
you've got this just complete look with
your makeup your eyebrows even the
freckles oh yeah it I mean like even the
highlights in your eye shadow that yeah
yes yes I really like it it's complete
yeah I want it today for you guys
I feel like I would switch with you do
you have makeup on I do yeah I think you
guys but it's like just because like you
both have like makeup on but I feel like
yours is just like a little bit more
like yeah you were wearing makeup I
wasn't sure about you so maybe that
would be a good switch I think everybody
does need like an artistic kind of
Outlet that's not where I would prefer
to put my artistic energy into like a
lot of people do use it kind of as a
security blanket makeup should be that
artistic Outlet versus like you know
something that you nobody can ever see
you without I like your makeup too yeah
I like your life like it's very fitting
for you yeah I see the sparkle that you
put in your inner corner and I love it
and I really want to keep you there
thank you yeah I think it's gorgeous I
think this actually is the first lineup
that was kind of easy I think we all
agree with this right yeah yeah okay
I need to put on mascara and a lip color
and at least cover up this and make this
look decent because this is a
distraction from like I could go out
like this and I feel just as confident
um but I just like that's me on my face
is when I do my makeup it's not for any
guys not for any girl it's for the
internet
yeah put it on so I can feel like a bad
not that I'm not a bad now
but like you know more I put the hands
over there
because she actually wanted like this
all the time so yes let's go to the
front let's do uh here I'll go just oh I
forgot what are you doing here wait oh
yeah we're just having a good discussion
yeah I feel like okay right here is good
because like you naturally don't wear
makeup so this is naturally how you
would look and we all still thought she
was bombing why did you move to the end
obviously like I feel very beautiful in
myself but like when I'm comparing to
like Society that's like I do not fit
being like Indian there's not a ton of
representations the represent that is
there is just like hyper like sexualized
or like just crazy like it's not normal
even when like representation for brown
skin women it's like when you think of a
black girl you're not thinking about me
most people still only like think like
mixed or like light skin or like you
know like that type of beauty standard
like and like I know like more recently
it's become more like popularized like
to oh melanin is beautiful black is
beautiful because it's like marketable
and it's like a thing now like people
used to call me Darth Vader when I was a
kid like you know what I mean so it's
like I've never been like the type of
person that girls or guys like check for
I'm Armenian you know Middle Eastern we
got the I had uh the little back hair um
I had a unibrow for sure I definitely
waxed my eyebrows I'm Armenian yes I
have lasered like so many parts of my
body just to be like hairless and like
why like why did I do it I don't know
just to like conform to society I would
also put her at one yeah instead yeah so
let's swap it yeah
awesome so like yeah my face I've had my
nose done I've had my nose done yeah
okay so we both yeah okay I don't know
so like yours looks more I guess like
what I would consider natural so that's
why I would make that switch
when like they want you to like go to
the end you're like you kind of get in
your head for a second thinking like oh
am I not pretty do they not think I'm
pretty do they not like this they're not
like that but it's just it's it's for
fun I don't think any of these women
think I'm unattractive I don't think any
of these women are unattractive I
totally wear Foundation to hide things
um you guys are just so natural I would
put myself back in the middle but I
think I would keep you there I like the
shape of your eyes and your face is very
symmetrical I feel like you're fighting
really hard to get out of that spot
we're going to keep you yeah we're
keeping you I told you we're locking you
in yeah but the break on babes bricks
are wrong
I'm gonna put you back to the front
I agree a thousand percent now when you
walked into the room it was like a it
was it was mystical
energy like you can feel your energy
when you walk in a room and that has I
think that's a lot to do with like the
way you carry yourself and just your
style your beauty everything I would
totally absolutely move you closer to
the front because you know who you are
you know your beauty and you know that
you are beautiful and you know exactly
what to do to play to it and the fact
that you use makeup as just an extension
of your beauty that already exists I you
walk into a room and you glow I would
move you up there I would too yeah
oh yeah get over here we weren't
supposed to cry today yeah I love you're
aesthetic too just like the hair and
like the style makeup like everything I
love your Vibes thank you also like um
and then you as well so I would move you
guys up I love your hair and your energy
and everything I also think I gravitate
more towards your energy too like I just
feel like you're very like
like present you know and which I really
like
yeah get on up there let's go I would
have still would put myself behind you
at at least you just know who you are I
would put you back up yeah I would
switch with you if it meant you could be
up here I
would put you like one just because like
they all said like you know who you are
you came in here with
no makeup and I feel like that was a
huge just like this is my face I like my
face um let's switch you yeah let's
let's get a movie or wait no should we
put just keep you here wait yeah yeah no
go back get you in front of me oh Jesus
yeah I agree with this I still think you
should still stay here if we're doing
like overall I'd put myself in front of
you for my style I agree personally the
complete look and energy and yeah I I
would switch with you myself yeah
yes
I don't know if I agree with that
switching necessarily just again like
just because like I prefer like your
kind of
less feminine yeah yeah I think it's
good just because like like you said you
kind of still struggle with like kind of
figuring out like your style and like
like where you balance out at and like I
feel like you're still very confident
and like just your overall like style in
general yeah you know so I think we're
good yeah I agree okay awesome
foreign
having a disability I my body is
changing and it's out of my own control
and the thing that I can control is the
way that I view myself I just don't view
myself right
we are we are like what's going to be as
mean to each other than we are to
ourselves you shouldn't put yourself
down you should be your biggest fan no
matter what you got to do what's best
for you and I think you know wear what
you want like wear makeup if you want
don't wear it if you don't want be you
and like it doesn't matter what anyone
else might think or judge about that